no but then I feel very on the other
times it then I'm gonna be uh nice the
other times
Andrew meeting big J exciting stop I
what is morning J like what are we
getting here wait we don't I find very
complaining in the streets yeah yeah
much case you don't drink coffee that's
what I just heard
chai chai okay there's some caffeine and
then yeah so you need caffeine in the
mornings I think so yeah I was just
talking about this Andrews work goes on
the road with me and he's like I think
I'm literally one of those people that
should be like talk to me till I've had
my coffee like I'm a bitch
my girlfriend does that to you she has
coffee right away yeah I don't she bitch
before it no she's just sort of like not
there oh she's all I got foggy yes I
guess until she gets I don't know I've
never I hate to taste a coffee so much
yeah it's gross it's not good sometimes
if I get you know if she gets like cream
in her coffee ever which she rarely does
but they make something looks the same
what I get I've drank hers by accident
and I childishly will go
[Music]
in my opinion everyone thinks they like
the taste of it but it's because it it's
like alcohol alcohol doesn't taste good
you have to put sugar and other in
it to make it taste good no naturally
children if the children aren't drawn to
coffee or alcohol cuz it's like look
like you actually no one enjoys the
taste it's always the idea if you give a
kid's like you know it's like the
cigarettes ting smoke the whole pack
with booze I think if you give a kid's
like a shot like beer or something young
a lot of times they get I remember
trying beer really young and not liking
and I never really drank till I was like
a legal age yes because it's gross yeah
it's so gross unless you get drunk as a
kid or your eight-year-old becomes an
alcoholic did you ever get to a point
where you were like sipping a whiskey I
never get that I believe everyone's
lying
I did it from like 23 to 26 I would
drink vodka on the rocks kettle on the
rocks and then I was in a scotch phase
cuz I felt like I was an adult I was
trying to impress no refreshment it does
get you up yeah I agree it's no
refreshment that's why I said if I drink
at all it's people always laugh the way
I drink but I just order three or four
children Everclear vodka or tequila and
then I just do all of them right away
with a diet coke right away and I'm like
okay I'm there that was I nursed that
it's why I sip on that just get it out
of the way take it like on an edible
yeah that's again I'm taking like it's a
drug go I want to get a little up
so I just like actually the healthiest
way I've heard of someone drinking
because you are taking it like it's a
drug like a pill you're just like okay I
want to get I want to feel a certain way
I'm measured it yeah and I'm gonna be
done because you don't have the
compulsion you said once you get drunk
too then just keep on truckin no the
only in fact Christine used to say all
the time that like not all the time but
she has so many stories of you when you
first start dating and you want to hear
everyone's sordid filthy past yeah she'd
get to these stories where it's like I
don't know is hanging out this guy and
his cousin like I think I the one
on
you know kind of what she goes I just
kinda remember coming to at one point I
think I was I don't know
she's like seems like very like and I'm
like that's not a thing
I've been pretty hammered before and the
problem is Wow why I hate getting like
too drunk is when I feel I'm too drunk
my brain stays oddly sober hmm not my
body or my words but my thought process
is still like dude you sound ridiculous
when you're talking you're wobbling when
you walk let's get through trapped in
your body the right functioning
correctly I've never had the other way
and then on one of those I've done those
cruise ships like rock bands they do
them so yeah it was Motorhead's cruise
ship I was doing and Christine was with
me and it's my first time ever on we
were doing a live podcasts for a SDR
show and I was you go I was think I
don't like whiskey and they go well how
about you if you ever tried fireball I
said no and they go that's like cinnamon
it tastes like candy
yup now still gets if it's whiskey it's
gonna have that whiskey taste boy it
doesn't I think I've had fireball shots
before very possible but at this we were
drinking it on the show just
aggressively drinking it and meanwhile
Christine was talking to there's a
Motorhead cruise so you figure it said
most gonna be mostly like you know
300-pound woman with faded tit tattoos
and there was one girl who came with the
DJ uh-huh she's like as a friend and was
hanging out with Christine the whole
time and Christine was still drinking at
the time so she was when she gets drunk
she'll get aggressive and she had gotten
the girl to come hang out she was like
yeah come look up with me and my
boyfriend yeah so I was drinking all
this fireball not even realizing how
drunk I was getting so it's like candy
and then that night I don't remember
this long crazy walk we went to some
secluded part of the boat the other girl
got naked I remember reaching up and
touching her ass and then going out and
I'm like really drunk I go maybe if I
just puke
I'll be able to rally so that was my
thought was which is a genuine good
thought really maybe I should run off
impute so I'm holding this girl's butt
cheek and then I just go yeah I'll get
this puke out I think I just looked over
and puked on my left shoulder completely
and then from that moment on it was do
you member requiem for a dream when they
anytime they would do drugs in the movie
it was like this weird quick montage it
would be like the noise of like a lion
being thing snort I get people gets
dilated when I was like four or five
shots or like in movies when someone's
coming in and out of like a coma and
they open their eyes and the scene is
always different like then it's like an
eye closed open I feel like I puked
closed my eyes open them I was in a
hallway with Christine and Ralph Sutton
like kind of carrying me this now I
would tell you how fast it went and then
I blinked again open my eyes looking at
the bottom of a trash can view King
closed my eyes opened up sat up in a bed
it was daytime out and I went wow I
didn't even feel like sick or anything I
was like what the was all that and
then Christine just looking at me like
yeah you blew it pretty bad I think you
touched that girl's ass and then was
like alright that's that that was a
one-time you blacked out that's it the
only time rising and when even when we
went back the next day I Christine lost
an earring or something in that part of
the boat we went to it was such a crazy
walk to get to this thing I was like
knives I don't remember any of this one
we went through like the back like stage
of a theater through some tunnel area we
did I don't remember any of them that's
the only thing I have so she loves that
night and that story because so many
years she be like I don't know I'm
pretty sure I hooked up with that guy
but I don't remember and I'm like
impossible I think you told me that
nighttime at night that they were
laughing at me and had me have sex with
a guy I mean like I did I could never
deny it try to be like a mega sad sex
with a guy they say and and and the
thing about blacking out when you're
drunk is your brain does no memory you
will
remember it because your brain didn't
keep that memory it's not storing
anything so there's nothing to even
remember even if you could
it didn't happen did it happen you a lot
Oh every time scary I never did anything
that wild my what what made me start to
go I have to stop doing this is that I
would snap and be really mean to my
friends like I would be like I would
hear the things I would say and I'd be
like I just don't feel that way about I
can't believe I would say that to you
so could you become a different person
that's what Christina stopped drinking
for I have a few friends that's the
that's one thing that's never had I
couldn't wrap my brain I said passing
out that definitely happened no one said
I was an asshole at all yeah but I've
never got that either if I was drunk out
of a place a bar or something and they
came over and said hey man like you're
gonna have to go I would just assume it
was me that was the problem I'd
pleasantly be like did I up I'm
sure I that horse must have been
me all right let me get out of here I'm
really sorry but I never understand you
get the I never understand that
when they're drunk and it's you going
like man if you were just sober you'd
realize how ridiculous you said but I've
never understood a mean drunk I would
just like turn on a friend and just be
weak I would just be weird I'd be like
what it was so just so humiliating how
weird I could be and I see I see it
happened to other people where I'm like
that is just you're beings your weirdest
self and it just felt I couldn't trust
myself and I couldn't trust myself not
to text people not to I would open up my
computer in the morning and I would have
a chat going a G chat where there was
definitely video going on and I wouldn't
remember of any of the things that I've
done on video with this guy but I'd seen
what we had said and I'd be like oh my
god like it was just yeah it was not
good to myself Christine stop drinking
from her last night drinking was rich
Voss roast I did it was right after
skank fest we did so it was three days
of her like working hard not getting
up so that the Vostro she wasn't
working that she got pretty hammered and
that night I just filmed her for 45
minutes being like belligerent
belligerent and then the next morning
Hasselhoff situation
hit play and like through their 45 set
they're teary-eyed and then went to a
meeting that day and never hasn't drank
since yeah good for you it was
ridiculous my favorite part of it this
is the highlight ultimately she goes
well first what does her complaint she
goes J you don't even have a producer's
bone in your body like some really an
insult and then she goes you think I'm
so supposable she goes yeah J suppose
what's the word look it up in the urban
dictionary and then I go I go there's
I'll look it up in any dictionary I
promise you suppose was not a word and
she goes look it up in any dictionary I
promise you is not a word and she goes
exactly just stupid like you just say
something you're like that's just weird
everything's weird and bad like I
finished the way substance hits certain
people to I and is probably why I don't
enjoy drugs or anything as much as a lot
of people I know is because I really
don't submit to it at all anytime I've
done mushrooms I'm all I remember it
completely I never have those like even
if I get that like wow look at those
patterns on the wall which you'll see if
somebody like stare at those and really
go like like creepily blank
mm-hm and I even if I go all the wall
looks really weird that's the mushrooms
of course you know I never really fully
submit to it at all which is uh does
that make you do it more that's what
makes me like excited to do it less like
almost but if I do it I'm like like I've
done now Molly a couple times yeah
pretty great I haven't done it yet
it's pretty fantastic actually but uh
but even Christina if I'd the two times
I've done her three times I've done it
I've been with her and she just it's
it's a full submission everything's the
next day it's like you know here's what
we gotta do in life it start like
everything from like home renovations to
like business ideas to why we're not -
and like it's constantly me go I'm like
I got that but before you start texting
the world
these ideas just understand you're on
Molly and I wanted to but I'm still a
person going like just sit on that for a
while and then tomorrow morning if you
still want to start your own shipping
and receiving business it's actually a
good if your sometimes I get to like
I'll smoke too much weed now like won't
have eaten enough I'm headed to the gym
or I'm get lightheaded and then I can I
can get into the panicky weed thing of
like anxiety like it could start
triggering my anxiety too but what
happens what I do which is what it seems
like you do because I remember my friend
Kirsten in high school being like I just
tell myself I'm high like when I start
to panic I go yeah you should be feeling
weird your hide you look at physical
manifestations of like the anxiety see I
get that and that's what I really have
to say to myself like yeah you're either
having a heart attack for nine years or
you're fine
why'd your I went to the ER thinking I
was having a heart attack because I did
to gravity bong hits after doing blow
all night with a stripper overlooking
Lake Pontchartrain whatever it was fun
in New Orleans but I put a pin in that
yeah we're just talking about life and
no but I went completely numb like from
Lake and I couldn't move off the couch
and I remember just going to my passing
I'm having a heart attack
he's like stop being a little bitch you
know like how your friends are nice to
you and he just dropped me off at the ER
you like even like stop you also drive
yourself yeah that was a fiber guy I
found
drivers are good ER I think I I got like
in 2010 I don't know if it was just like
a psyche like psychological burst or
something but I went to the hospital a
bunch in like a month and I was having
all these physical manifestations I
thought it was weed doing it was just
anxiety but even if anxiety induced by
weed or just your brain what's so it's
amazing how physical it can get because
and I think this is just my own idea but
it seems to be whatever you think your
problems gonna be and the symptoms of
that so it would be that my right arm
would go
um you know and you'd be like oh ah this
is the stroke let's say you have a
stroke you'll get the things that like
you'll manifest that the the things
that's what are useful for me was always
like numb limbs yeah and then you I'm
just like forced myself to go to sleep
or if you just keep I your mind and it
still happens the best so what I do
today so I get it today where I'm like I
get a little anxious from smoking too
much we eat are you strong weed you just
gotta like now you know let's just talk
though if we just have a conversation
get your thoughts off that because if
you lean into that thought it will
physically manifest thoughts come first
and then they become feelings people
think feelings make thoughts it's really
thoughts or driving what you feel so get
out of that thought it's exactly that
distract yourself that's or you could
but also like you don't if you're
getting the numbness or a pain and
you're like sometimes I'll get a pain in
my neck they tell you to lean it don't
try to make it go away
and you're brilliant it's gonna go away
it's gonna go you're just like no it's
there you acknowledge it and then you
should just yeah but like that is
another way is just think like go to
yeah and like lean into it and don't
think about where it's going but just
feel the pain and yeah and feel the
numbness no and that it's like a thing
that is not happening to you it's just a
yeah there's a lot of time it will
brought on by drugs though or something
a feeling to this thing is you will get
through that you know the time of that
will pass exactly but it's funny that we
don't you don't get freaked out when you
have physical manifestations from other
emotional you know if like a heartbreak
like us a crushing heartbreak you do you
feel that thing like almost when you
stand in front of a fire like place
where you get you feel like you're
shrink you know like that numbness to
your body you can see something that
breaks your heart and feel that and you
don't go I'm having a heart attack you
just know that's the feeling of like
that's a good you know you're going down
but when it's drugs you're like because
there's always some tinge and you it's
going like I'm done this is the one's
gonna kill me yeah and I write on a drug
and then that's it
yeah but sometimes I'm right like me
Jaime is right about the thing I'm
saying about myself like I get for the
physical thing but let me go I'll be
like I'm a loser or something but
not broadly but link it'll be for a very
specific reason that's true and the next
day I'm sober and I'm like Jaime
like was right about that
why give me an example I think I think
being introspective on drugs yes surely
isn't always like a wrong thing I think
that can be right right yes sometimes
you have like these realizations that
the next day you go oh my gosh yeah that
was a cool like I like to get high
because it opens my mind to like
thoughts that I don't normally have like
I acknowledge that it does take me to a
place that I can't get sober yet I
probably could because it's all in my
head nothing's really changing it's
accessible but pot helps me access it
also if you're something you're panicky
about or whatever the good thing and
you'll be right sometimes about being on
like you know it's particularly weed or
something like that when you do have the
thoughts like I've just because that's
what most people take drugs for is to
drop your shoulders and girls like
things are gonna be alright for a while
like a lot of times you're right they
are you know it's like it's like you
realize like when you're not high you're
like I'm getting wound up over something
that's just not that big of a deal yeah
and the other night like before a show
Hill's just start clearing his throat
like he's got something in his throat
and it happens before every single show
and and I go okay you're cleaning your
throat
literally this happens you know that
there's not something in your throat
right now like yeah like it's but that
is an exact physical manifestation of
emotions I mean it happens every time do
you find that that's what happens to you
and you don't think that I should try
this I can't I don't overthink it I try
not to
something's happening because it's a
feeling helps you go okay this shouldn't
be happening it kind of I know well I I
just can't sit before show I just keep I
don't know I like I like walking I like
pacing sure I just enjoyed it just get
my brain gone it sounds like though that
you think you're choking sometimes and
I'm like you're not choking no I yeah
I've gotten over the having I chew on
one side swallow on one side like I'm
kind of up about choking because
of that one instance where I thought I
was joking and then it like grew from
there it's all panic induced it's like
it's insane but like I'll think
something's in my throat when it's not
in my throat and then I'm like well it's
gonna choke me eventually insane I don't
think I'm more but
9 level like you're hanging out with
friends this is more I guess like guys
would care more about this though and
like it's a sad movie or something or a
sad part where you know if you were
alone like this is something I might cry
at or this is the part where people are
gonna think I'm gonna cry and then
there's non-stop something in your eye
you have to keep doing it happens to me
a lot where I'm like anybody probably
guys not crying on here I don't even
care about this girl with Down syndrome
in this video you search your body finds
a way to get it out like it's something
just you have to rub that I for some
reason you cry at all more than an adult
man should for sure
yeah oh yeah that's great in public I've
never cried at a funeral I've never
cried no showers long far right yeah
music hits me never cry alone music well
I was going through a really hard
breakup one time and I won't need to cry
so bad I was just going through the
worst pain but I couldn't cry alone
because I just I just feel like it's
like looking at yours it's like
masturbatory feels stupid to me which
also I have struggles with doing it was
just so stupid so I would put on
noise-cancelling headphones and blast
the air like white noise so I couldn't
hear myself crying so that I could cry
without the knowledge that I was crying
I can't cry I think crying alone feels
I mean sometimes a movie will get me but
I'll never just like like crying alone
times I asked for it's like sometimes I
take into the music that I'm like yeah I
got a 45-minute car ride that's really
sounds what's your song a choice to cry
too it could be anything there's so many
things like you know anyone what you're
going through at the time yeah it's like
a tease rockers it could be a number
like a ballad and the weirdest song the
verve the drugs don't work is one of the
saddest songs I'll put that on sometimes
what I'm feeling sad what's yours
Depeche Mode was really sad I remember
when I was a kid as anything it's got
kind of that guy like as lame as it
sounds like Marilyn Manson's sadder
slower salt no no metal stuff is like
very touching dark
mashing pumpkins have a few songs they
can get me for sure what are your crotch
acts minor like I know it's like like
like like girly so meet you dude I'm a
no father Madonna brutal oh I don't know
that one any father issues at all
there's a line that says about the
father being you know he's a shitty
father to her but it's because somebody
she says like somebody hurt you too I'm
ruining my daughter bride Everclear yeah
like she like that I never cry from
happiness yeah I've never done that I
definitely have done that really oh
definitely
yeah yeah I don't I got a parakeet for
Christmas and when I realized I opened
this package that was a parakeet toy and
I was looked up and I was like yeah yeah
I think I've cried from like something
being touching like in a happy way I'll
tell you the crying problem I've had
lately these two times that really I'm
confused myself on the emotions of it
took my parents to see guns and roses of
the garden and I mean on songs like
welcome to the jungle I'm like holding
back like trying and I thank ya and kiss
I'm not a huge kiss fan but I've always
wanted to see I know a bunch of their
music but they were doing that last tour
so we went a couple weeks ago
and they came out to Detroit Rock City
flames fire they're coming down and I
was getting emotional and I'm telling
you what it is age 8 I'm looking at that
and I go man
this is like some like Guns and Roses
particularly is like a band
they were my music when they came out
that my parents were even like what is
this garbage not and now I'm taking them
to see him Axl Rose was like an old lady
everyone you know I mean like slashes
skin is
it's way happy cry wasn't even a sad cry
it's just like a realization sound I'm
40 yeah it's just like I remember
writing my mom her 40th birthday card
yeah when I was like you know I was 20
you were an adult when you were writing
your mom's for April right now I'm yeah
they just hit you like that it's even
when kiss came out I'm like found
staring at like God when people cry cuz
they're looking out beautiful sunset or
whatever it's so beautiful you're just
like life is beautiful and long and
weird and have you left your mark have
you left your legacy and then I don't
and we're back at you up with Nikki
Glaser when do I get to this Noah
whenever I want to feel like I think I
would appeal on that litter that maybe
in the pool that there would be the
changing color yeah you would be
frightened of that but do you
I learned that swimmers pain pools likes
people who like all professional
swimmers just pee in the pool yeah
constantly I didn't know that I would
think that they were like respectful
like you don't piss on the fields but
they just are pissing cuz Laurieann
Gibson football players my buddy would
piss their pants just cuz it give us too
hard to take everything off so it's good
intimidation he's Rica pissed
myself there is nothing better than when
you get into a hot tub and you're like
body it's time to pee and you just like
don't care and you let it go you're like
alone and you think oh when I scare my
friend in the eyes or in the ocean and
rude that was the first time you
masturbated was rubbing up on the jets
in his mom's jacuzzi yeah did you finish
I couldn't come yet just to get this
tingly feeling it was better than coming
it was like oh yeah the ghost went from
like oh my god when you would comment
anyway just a little just what were you
what were you banging what was the first
things that you were kind of just your
hand did you get did you get one I was
always hand I was oh no my so funny how
I not tight me and my dad are and never
were but would I go think back of all
the weird things I'm like yeah he
probably shouldn't be that into me right
see when I'd go to his house in the
summertime yeah I used to pay a very
cheap furniture I remember I used to
it almost like it was doggy style
no interesting because I didn't know
what coming was I just see that the
magazines were a thing I were just pee a
little bit on the cushion and then my
stepmothers doesn't like me to this day
and we're so I don't blame her fully
shouldn't even know this happened but
and then I'll just flip the cushion
start again the next day
there's come on yeah no come Oh crying
piss and it was asking for it
why else would have wear flowers start
off the lower back touch oh my god what
were you thinking how old were you yeah
it just feels great you're not really
thinking sex thoughts when that's going
on no it was sex I would be like taking
my like find my dad's porn oh you would
okay so you were looking at my dad had
that porn that was like on thick stalk
because it would show actual penetrate
but I was back in the old magazines were
pretty much even if it was girl guy girl
stuff it was all like suggestive it was
like dick to the right dick near
the shots yeah okay well shots even just
like they would put whatever you know
they decorate the girl and she was like
yeah and then and that was it but they
had so he had like the
paper-like once you have to get like in
a real sex shop Wow it was like
penetration a lot of Bush oh wow
which is really held up in my interests
that do you like it on when you're
hooking up yeah
Wow like undercarriage or just like
front like unruly or anything however I
will say because there's very few every
I've ever seen that's had hair on
it that wasn't like you know crazy like
a mob unruly yeah would picket sign
[Laughter]
control it okay yeah not unruly not
unruly but uh I've seen more bald
pussies that don't look good because
they're bald and I've never seen a bad
looking that's got like maintained
hair yeah I I totally agree I think
that's what's made girls so insecure
about their vaginas now because if a
china's do look insane there's some of
them are kind of gross looking and you
see it all now because there's no hair
that used to hide it off also some
people just don't react well to shaving
boss and then you get like they are
covered in sores or like yeah well
you're a true hero I appreciate that you
don't like you don't need a bush I mean
if I would really that would be amazing
thing if a guy that I was dating was
into a bush yeah I mean I come down some
people me and soda go but I think sodas
like more fan of the ball and I show
them like ones with hair and I'm like oh
my god this is he's like oh that's fine
I guess you like totally bald Andrew for
sure yes just being ever get there no no
I like I like I could do a strip but I I
just want to clean underneath underneath
just like are like fighting through the
fort like to get to the
it's like I think it's a little much
David a Greek girl once who had such a
crazy Bush and I was like that's fun for
a little bit like a month of dating or
so I was like would it be sexy if I
shaved your did she was like a
projectile squirter it was being held
back behind that thick patch of couldn't
get through that just like so get a
beard insane so that means you found a
nice discovery it was pretty so got a
kitten reached out to a lot by the youth
yeah America I don't know what's going
on euthanasia they listened to the show
and there's like young guys that are
into what I'm putting out and it's kind
of like I didn't hook up until I was in
my like mid to mid 20s I didn't get
around so I didn't get any of this 21
year old action when I was actually of a
around their age appropriate yes listen
I'm of age I can date a 21 year old
whatever yeah you could a 18 year old
that feels weird but I could um I'm old
enough to go to war old enough to eat
your Bush yeah I'm yeah yeah all my guns
and cigarettes they're old enough to go
down I'm a 34 year old woman that's in
their prime yeah who's in her prime
who's learning about her body who knows
what she wants kind of get in that
bunker like I wouldn't I'd be like
you're welcome because like I'm gonna
teach you the way yeah nothing like I
wouldn't be like nervous like am I gonna
be bad cuz they're gonna be bad yeah
yeah they're looking for you for
guidance like a mrs. Robinson
I do think that a young kid that's
athletic conveying the great yeah let's
yeah athletic yes doesn't feel
comfortable with like even talk yeah the
idea of banging this kid that doesn't
sound good
it's not a kid it's a 21 year old man
with kid features you tell me that's the
thing I'm like does he look like a kid
because if I'm gonna try to do this 21
year old who actually looks very young
for his age there's something wrong with
me and that's why I don't even want to
like guys that date girls that look like
children you're like yeah you're
following the laws but this just looks
gross okay let me I gotta say cuz I got
to show you I'm gonna get it we get into
okay I'm 21
okay and I don't think 13 years is a big
deal oh that's a good line great line
I'm 34 he's 21 he did the math cuz he
learned it in school recently him probs
that yeah now he he just learned
subtraction so subtracted 21 from 304
yeah we get 13 I'm 21 and I don't think
13 years is a big deal now that the
first couple of words caught your
attention I just want to say I listened
to your podcast every Monday and I
definitely feel the same way you do
about relationships and intimacy so what
do you think he means by that what do
you think I put out there on this show
he says he he's a little uncomfortable
with it yeah yeah yeah okay um so if you
ever want some string free oral sex
which he means no strings attached
oh I tell you man tampon yeah I thought
he heard string too and I'm like okay I
can almost guarantee you that I won't
have a string down there I'm gonna have
you go down I can't guarantee I mean I
can almost guarantee it sometimes you
forget he'll eat around it you know
that's what I always say yeah if you
find it'll be like um can you just um I
know what you're seeing here you bet I
can you oh you don't really happen to
girls before what I offered that one
time I hooked up with a girl when she
was on a cruise and I was like she was
yeah we well we both were yeah she was
on Tom Cruise and I was just she was on
her period and I told her I'd I was
really drunk and I was like heat around
it how you did it and she goes yeah good
that's so gross then yeah Ian let me
wait we still talked so if you ever want
so if you ever want some string free
oral sex and first of all have I talked
about how I love oral sex more than
anything that I don't honestly what you
talked about you want someone to claim
them on their like a what the womanizer
yeah like I like hear that um yeah and
they like certain styles of oral sex but
a 21 year old is not that's not what I
would prefer even a guy doing that's not
what it was yes so I feel like he's
saying like I'm listening to your needs
you're not true I want to get I like I
would like to have sex with this person
man fully grown man legal this old kid
and by the way I don't know that I do
yeah is really key that will see um and
he said so if you ever want some string
free oral sex such a funny way to think
it sounds like he's from another country
I mean that's a lady trying to adopt our
idioms but no this kid is an American
our education systems it really that's
what I wanted to talk about today is
that I mean the grammar of this message
alone is cause for concern so if you
ever want some string for your oral sex
in a night time blunt before I leave let
me know this guy is just gonna go down
on me leave a blunt on my nightstand and
just go good god what is wrong with this
this sounds good go to for more or what
I can see you going to formal and Destin
I just don't want to die with any
regrets of like why didn't I bang more
21-year olds who were dying to bang me
like they want it's not like I'm
tricking him into it he's dying
yeah I don't see in 13 years isn't that
much it's a it's a teenager between us
which also sounds good
[Music]
if you liked this clip from you up with
Nikki Glaser please share it with
someone that you care about
spread the word it means a lot to me get
it out there everybody get the word out
because we're the best this isn't a we
that you're you joined me sometimes
we're here every Monday through Thursday
any other information that you have
about the show so we we get down the
things the nitty-gritty everything you
we tackle subjects that not a lot of
people will tackle we're not afraid of
anything